hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
Assassin's Creed has had many ups and
downs through the years with the beacon
of light being NGO and the cities that
be resided in how to kill your who are
you dying
Black Flag was another world-changing
affair but the ones in between were that
fantastic many people have decided to
abandon the Assassin's Creed series what
after a year off Ubisoft has brought
back Messiah and Wow it's damn good here
are six ways Assassin's Creed origins
evolves the series into a must-play
title again let's start with the eagle
seenu do my eyes jello I realize it's
just a living version of the drone from
Ghost Recon wildlands but this inclusion
brings planning into Assassin's Creed
like never before he can Scout mark
targets and notice locations for later
missions without the clumsy animus
overlay which took many of us away from
the immersion of all the places that we
visited seenu feels like an organic and
fitting way to forward think and
planning origins and just look at his
face all you cute little boogers origins
has revamped the combat system terrible
not that it wasn't great before but the
enemies would gather round and wait for
their turn to die well a few subtle
changes are now in place the lock-on
system is key to each battle with life
and heavy attack yielding combo you will
need to charge an attack to break
through an enemy's defense and the
animations are more organic now and less
scripted and blocked out there's
definitely still room to button bash
like you're playing Tekken Daddy
god--all but accomplished fighters will
be able to do so much more
the adrenaline bar can be built up by
beating the [ __ ] out of everyone until
your special attack is ready to be
unleashed
if close-up combat isn't your thing then
the usual options to take enemies from a
distance are through self actions are
here too the enemies in origins appear
to be more intelligent than previous
iterations to the game with the more
agile goons running to call for help or
light a signal fire the ones holding
shields will adapt to your actions such
as taking a step back while you charge
your heavy attack to stay centimeters
out of your attack zone the gals who
like to battle will continuously found
you and calm
they push you back making each encounter
feel like a real fight to the death
you'll also find that once you've taken
a few out the remaining attackers will
be much more cautious origins also
brings back traditional bosses and new
services who you'll encounter regularly
these bosses are extremely varied with
the two that we fought using a huge axe
with a massive area of damage and
another one who looked like Russell
Crowe in Gladiator and zips around the
fight with the greatest of ease
fight variation is something that the
Assassin's Creed series hasn't really
had in the past so the kudos are
definitely deserved on this one like so
many games a loop system has been put
into the Assassin's Creed series and
know it was there before but this one is
straight-up
RPG looting this feels a lot like the
division with enemies dropping items and
weapons with a color-coded system of
importance and rarity legendary items
have increased stat bonuses or special
abilities meaning finding one of these
bad boys is and invent all of its own
the loot you uncover will force you to
make choices to do I stick with my sword
which I've had for hours or do I upgrade
to this epic spear but then I've got to
learn to fight again these little
nuances make the role-playing element of
this game much more emphasized this all
ties into how you fight in the previous
two points shield resistance quiz and
volume glove range for melee attacks
there's so many areas the loop system
will change if you haven't noticed we're
here in Egypt so who needs history class
when we can live it for ourselves we'll
be playing as byuk which sounds
ridiculous but even more amusing than
that if you're from the north of England
like me byuk is a toned-down way of
saying bloody ell so bloody hell what a
great name that is we will be learning
about how the Assassin's Creed was
formed and byuk looks to be one of the
first ever so that six ways Assassin's
Creed origins involves the series what
do you think of this one are you going
to try it and what was the last
Assassin's Creed game you loved for me
it was Black Flag there are so many
things to talk about such as The Witcher
3 s elements the series has brought in
and also that ability tree to build by
akin to the warrior you want him to be
I'm Adam from Playstation grenade and
for more about Assassin's Creed origins
well you're already in the right
as always it's been a pleasure I'll see
you next time
boom boom boom let me say way oh way oh
boom boom I Maxton